I was so hungry to keep programming in APL that when I went to the engineering building and discovered it to be locked, I saw that I could just stick a twig in the door and essentially unlock it and break my way in. Welcome to ADSB The Podcast, episode 49, recorded on October 3rd, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Price, we continue part two of our interview with Dave Abrahams, which covers topics including BASIC, APL, C++, and so much more. If you haven't seen part one, check out episode 48, which was part one of this two-part interview. Can I ask you a question?
当时我对继续用 APL 编程极度渴望，以至于当我去工程大楼发现门锁着时，我发现自己只要把一根树枝插进门缝里，基本上就能打开锁，破门而入。欢迎收看 ADSB 播客第 49 期，录制于 2021 年 10 月 3 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我的联合主持人是布赖斯（Price），我们继续进行对戴夫·艾布拉姆斯（Dave Abrahams）访谈的第二部分，内容涵盖 BASIC、APL、C++ 以及更多话题。如果你还没看过第一部分，请收听第 48 期，那是这期两部分访谈的第一部分。我能问你一个问题吗？
I just realized I don't know what ADSP stands for. And so I don't know what audience we're talking to and what this podcast is about. ADSP stands for Algorithms Plus Data Structures Equals Programs, stolen from the Nicholas Wirth book. Beautiful. I'm not actually sure if we've ever described why we chose that one. You mean the real reason or the other reason?
我刚意识到我不知道 ADSP 代表什么。所以我不知道我们在和什么样的听众对话，以及这个播客是关于什么的。ADSP 代表算法加数据结构等于程序，盗用了尼古拉斯·维尔特（Niklaus Wirth）的书。太棒了。我其实不确定我们是否曾经描述过为什么选择这个。你是说真正的原因还是另一个原因？
There's two reasons? I don't even know. What are the two reasons that you know? The pragmatic reason is that when you have algorithms and data structures in your podcast title, it means that it's pretty good SEO, search engine optimization, but there's other reasons.
有两个原因吗？我甚至都不知道。你知道的两个原因是什么？功利的原因是，当你的播客标题里有算法和数据结构时，意味着它的 SEO（搜索引擎优化）会相当不错，但还有其他原因。
Oh, right. Is it the unofficial one that one of our Twitter followers pointed out that someone said it's a unofficially discussion with Sean parent? Yes. Because we've had him on, we've only talked to him three times, but we always, we always, you know, squeeze as much content out. And so we turned those three recordings into like nine episodes.
哦，对。是不是我们的一位推特粉丝指出的那个非官方原因，有人说这是与肖恩·帕伦特（Sean parent）的非官方讨论？是的。因为我们邀请过他，我们只跟他聊过三次，但我们总是，总是，你知道的，榨取尽可能多的内容。所以我们将这三次录音转化成了大约九集节目。
But yeah, the first four episodes of the show were us talking about our favorite algorithms and data structures. And it's, it's mostly an open-ended, sometimes we bring guests on to hear about their stories and experience. And sometimes we're just randomly, you know, right before you joined, I had been wanting to explain my love that is developing for combinatory logic and combinators, which are these little, you know, composition patterns that a few of them exist in Haskell and a lot of them exist in APL, which is like my favorite language at the moment um that was one of my first uh languages actually all right so here I'm going to turn this interview on its head because Bryce's introduction quickly dived into uh oh do you know about this boo story and I was like Bryce I said we wanted to go back to the beginning and then we just we we skipped to like all right we can go back to whatever you want to go back but i'm so i'm um i'm super curious yeah like how did you get to the you know 1998 point where boost pro and boost con
但是，是的，节目的前四集是我们讨论我们最喜欢的算法和数据结构。而且，它基本上是一个开放式的，有时我们会邀请嘉宾来听听他们的故事和经验。有时我们只是随性地，你知道的，就在你加入之前，我一直想解释我正在萌芽的对组合逻辑和组合子的热爱，这些是小小的，你知道的，组合模式，其中一些存在于 Haskell 中，很多存在于 APL 中，APL 就像我目前最喜欢的语言，嗯，那其实是我的第一门语言之一。好吧，所以在这里我要彻底颠覆这次访谈，因为布赖斯的介绍很快就切入了，哦，你知道这个 Boo 的故事吗？然后我就像，布赖斯，我说过我们想回到起点，然后我们直接，我们跳到了，好吧，我们可以回到你想回到的任何地方，但我非常，我，我超级好奇，是的，比如你是怎么走到，你知道的，1998 年那个节点，当时 Boost Pro 和 Boost Con
and all that stuff started and then you i don't know if it's how many chapters has it been since then but there's the c++ chapter at sort of boost pro and i'm not even sure if that was all of your time was spent at Boost Pro there, or there was some before and after. Then you had your Swift chapter at Apple. Then that chapter sort of continued or evolved into Swift for TensorFlow at Google. And now you're at Adobe.
以及诸如此类的事情开始了，然后你，我不知道从那时起已经过了多少个章节，但在某种程度上，在 Boost Pro 有 C++ 的篇章，我甚至不确定你是否把所有的时间都花在了那里的 Boost Pro，还是在那之前和之后有一些。然后你在苹果公司经历了 Swift 的篇章。然后那个篇章在谷歌以某种方式延续或演变成了 TensorFlow 的 Swift。现在你在Adobe。
So there's all of that stuff. But I have no idea what happens to the point where you were starting that series of chapters if you had been doing C++. So the fact that you're mentioning APL, and that's the thing is I have started to discover that these people that are known for certain things like Stepanov, known for STL, known for C++, spent a decade in scheme preaching the beauty of LISPs and has one of his talks talks about how APL with its arrays and LISPs with its, you know, homoiconic, you know, parentheses and small talk with its object model.
所以有所有这些东西。但我完全不知道在你开始这一系列篇章的时候，如果你一直在做 C++，事情是怎么发展到那个地步的。所以你提到 APL 的事实，这就是事情所在，我已经开始发现，这些因某些事情而闻名的人，比如斯捷帕诺夫（Stepanov），因 STL 闻名，因 C++ 闻名，却在 Scheme 中度过了十年，宣扬 LISP 的美妙，并且他的一次演讲谈到 APL 的数组和 LISP 的，你知道的，同像性，你知道的，括号，以及 Smalltalk 的对象模型。
Like, and he, he stole ideas, stole or borrowed ideas from all of these languages. And like, I can't, I knew, I thought I knew everything about Stepanov. And then apparently there was a whole decade of his career that he spent in Scheme and even prototyped a ton of his ideas in C++ in scheme. So yeah, let's rewind to whether it's age six when you started programming or university and then take us to share as much as you want up until the point that you were doing all the Boost Pro and Boost Con stuff. All right. Okay.
就像，他，他从所有这些语言中偷取了想法，偷取或借用了想法。而且，我不能，我以为我对斯捷帕诺夫了如指掌。然后显然他职业生涯的整整十年都是在 Scheme 中度过的，甚至在 Scheme 中用 C++ 原型化了大量他的想法。所以，是的，让我们倒带，不管是你六岁开始编程还是上大学，然后带我们分享你想分享的内容，直到你做所有 Boost Pro 和 Boost Con 相关事情的那个点。好的。好的。
It all started at a, you're not going to believe how this dates me, at a teletype with a paper tape punch and reader on the side of it. This was a terminal on a time-sharing system at my school, my middle and high school. The time-sharing system was a PDP-8, which was about a refrigerator-sized unit with a magnetic tape drive on the front, no disks. It was so timeshared basic to a bunch of teletypes positioned throughout the school. Actually, I think there was just, there was one downstairs in the lower school and then there was, and then there was a cluster in the same room as the same room as the PDPA. And it was, the operating system was essentially basic. On the front, there were, there were actual switches for, for entering binary bits. And if you wanted to program it from the front panel, you could flip a bunch of switches and then flip another switch and that would enter that binary number into the address space.
这一切都始于一个，你不会相信这暴露了我有多老，一个带有纸带打孔机和侧面读带机的电传打字机。这是我学校（我的初中和高中）的分时系统上的一个终端。分时系统是一台 PDP-8，大约冰箱大小，前面有一个磁带驱动器，没有磁盘。它通过分时将 BASIC 提供给学校各处的许多电传打字机。实际上，我认为只有，楼下的低年级有一个，然后有，然后有一个集群在和 PDP-8 相同的房间里。而且，操作系统基本上就是 BASIC。在前面，有，有实际的开关，用来，用来输入二进制位。如果你想从前面板对它编程，你可以拨动一堆开关，然后拨动另一个开关，这就会将那个二进制数输入到地址空间中。
So it was running BASIC and I was introduced to it by one of my classmates. I don't even remember who. And there were a bunch of B computer games on there. In fact, they all came, if I remember right, from a book called 101 Basic Computer Games by Dave Hall, A-H-L, which was, you know, immediately hooked. And from there, there was a 6502 breadboard prototyping system from Heath kit that the school had. And I, and I took that home and I, I figured out how to program in assembly language and, and made a tiny little, you know, car racing game on the LEDs and cause yeah, games. So that was the, that was the start. This is all in high school or? Middle school is junior high. And yeah, my dad was a physicist at Rutgers. And when he saw how interested I was, he mentioned that they have PDP-10 at his lab, which was where they were doing bubble chamber research. So bubble chambers are essentially a thing in which they track particle trails after collisions. And maybe I want to check that out.
所以它运行的是 BASIC，我的一位同班同学把我引向了它。我甚至不记得是谁了。上面有一堆 B 电脑 games。事实上，如果我没记错的话，它们都来自一本名为戴夫·霍尔（Dave Ahl，A-H-L）的《101 个 BASIC 电脑游戏》的书，这让我，你知道的，立刻就上瘾了。从那以后，学校有一个来自 Heathkit 的 6502 面包板原型系统，我，我把它带回家，我，我弄明白了如何用汇编语言编程，并在 LED 上制作了一个微小的，你知道的，赛车游戏，因为，是的，游戏。所以那就是，那就是开始。这都是在高中还是？初中就是初级中学。是的，我爸爸是罗格斯大学的物理学家。当他看到我对这有多感兴趣时，他提到他的实验室里有一台 PDP-10，那是他们进行气泡室研究的地方。所以气泡室本质上是一个用来追踪碰撞后粒子轨迹的东西，也许我想去看看。
And so I went there and it was this giant room. You walked inside the computer to go inside the room. And there were a couple of hard disks the size of washing machines and lots of core memory uh you know the little magnets little uh toroidal magnets on the wires and uh and they had they had a much faster paper tape punch and reader they had uh they had a line printer which made a lot of noise a line printer chugs out it it basically sets chooses on let's see there's like 128 columns each of which has a cylinder that has all of the possible characters on it and and so each line it prints it rotates the the cylinders
于是我去了那里，这是一个巨大的房间。你走进计算机内部才能进入那个房间。里面有几个洗衣机大小的硬盘和大量的磁芯内存，你知道的，线上的小磁铁，小环形磁铁，嗯，而且它们有一个快得多的纸带打孔机和读带机，它们有，它们有一台行式打印机，噪音非常大，行式打印机哒哒哒地打印，它基本上，选择，让我们看看，大约有 128 列，每一列都有一个圆柱体，上面有所有可能字符，因此它打印的每一行，都会旋转圆柱体
to the right position and then it slams them against the paper. So that was a print a whole line at once. That's called a line printer. Makes a lot of noise. And the PDP-10 manual that I got a hold of had descriptions of several languages that they had. Obscure things like Tico, and that I think was a text editing language, but also Algol, uh, which I, I tried to learn, uh, never actually got anywhere with that. A more sophisticated version of basic that, that lab also had a, a Tektronix terminal in it on which you could play a game with,
到正确的位置，然后它们猛击在纸上。所以那是整行打印的。这被称为行式打印机。噪音很大。我弄到的 PDP-10 手册里有他们拥有的几种语言的描述。一些晦涩的东西，比如 Tico，我认为那是一种文本编辑语言，还有 Algol，嗯，我，我试着学过，嗯，实际上并没有取得任何进展。该实验室还有一个更复杂的 BASIC 版本，里面有一个泰克（Tektronix）终端，你可以在上面玩一个游戏，
you know, where asteroids attack your spaceship and you try and shoot them down. And that was unlike anything, you know, a few years later and you're trying to shoot them down and that was unlike anything you know a few years later you would see that stuff in the arcade but it was unlike anything i had ever seen at at that point yeah so so that was pretty exciting but it required you know a 45 minute commute with my dad into into work uh, uh, to, to do anything. And let's see, my, my mother was, uh, was a choreographer at Princeton teaching dance. And so I, I found out how I could get access to computers through her. And, uh, I got, I got some account, uh, on the Princeton university systems, which is where I discovered APL.
你知道的，小行星攻击你的飞船，你试着把它们击落。这与任何，你知道的，几年后你在游戏机厅里看到的东西截然不同，但它与我当时见过的任何东西都不同，是的，所以，所以这挺令人兴奋的，但它需要，你知道的，和我爸爸一起通勤 45 分钟才能去上班，嗯，去，去做任何事情。然后，你看，我，我妈妈是，嗯，普林斯顿大学的编舞，教舞蹈。所以，我，我发现我可以通过她接触到计算机，嗯，我，我在普林斯顿大学系统上获得了一些账号，嗯，在那里我发现了 APL。
Was that a shorter commute? Is that why? Yeah. Sorry. I lived in Princeton. Okay. Yeah. Thanks, dad. But mom's university is closer. Yeah. Yeah. But although I think that I wasn't supposed to be using a lot of that equipment and nobody was paying much attention to where I was going, but you know, I was just a teenager, no affiliation with the university.
那是较短的通勤时间吗？这就是原因吗？对。抱歉。我住在普林斯顿。好的。好的。谢谢爸爸。但妈妈的大学更近。对。对。不过尽管我认为我不应该使用很多那些设备，而且没有人太注意我要去哪里，但你知道，我只是一个青少年，与这所大学没有任何关系。
And at some point I was, I was so hungry to keep programming an APL that, that when I went to the engineering building and discovered it to be locked, I, you know, I saw that I could just stick a twig in the door and essentially unlock it, break my way in and go use the computers. This is amazing. This is, oh my goodness. It's APL is so addictive. You hear that?
在某个时候，我，我太渴望继续用 APL 编程了，以至于，当我走到工程大楼发现它锁着时，我，你知道，我发现我只要把一根树枝插进门缝里，基本上就能打开锁，破门而入去使用电脑。这太神奇了。这，哦天哪。APL 太让人上瘾了。你听到了吗？
Dave Abraham's is a creator of Swift. We're talking about here. Well, not creator. One of the main key contributors responsible for the standard library of Swift. Uh, it was in love with APL. All right, wait, this is keep it going. This is, this is amazing. Yeah. So, I mean, APL appealed in part because I, you know, I would watch my dad do his work. He was a theoretical physicist. So when I watch him do his work, what he's writing down on the,
戴夫·艾布拉姆斯是 Swift 的创造者。我们在这里谈论的。好吧，不是创造者。负责 Swift 标准库的主要关键贡献者之一。嗯，曾经迷恋 APL。好吧，等等，继续。这，这太神奇了。是的，所以，APL 之所以吸引人，部分原因是我，你知道的，我会看着我爸爸做他的工作。他是一位理论物理学家。所以当我看着他做他的工作时，他在，
on the paper, these, all of these mysterious and magical symbols that had some kind of deep meaning about the universe. And APL is a lot like that. It's full of these Tektronix terminals where you could use APL to make graphics and APL having matrix multiplies, you know, matrix transformation built in and lots of array support for like long lists of points and things. It really lent itself well to this kind of work kind of work so i played around with that stuff i was really interested in in 3d and sort of figured out that i could that by making an angular map of the world i could actually create perspective in 2d so it's for the kinds of
纸上写的，所有这些神秘而神奇的符号，对宇宙有着某种深层的意义。APL 就很像那样。它充满了这些泰克终端，你可以在上面使用 APL 制作图形，APL 拥有内置的矩阵乘法，你知道的，内置的矩阵变换，以及对长点列表等的大量数组支持。它确实非常适合这种工作，这种工作，所以我玩过那些东西，我对 3D 非常感兴趣，并且不知怎么地发现，通过制作世界的角度地图，我实际上可以在 2D 中创造透视，所以它类似于，
things i was playing with were you just all like it sounds like you were just sneaking in and and self-teaching like did you have like an apl manual or like how would you like because it's not a simple thing to just oh i've i've seen into the meaning of this unicode symbol now i know what it means uh oh this is before unicode my man uh yeah there was no unicode back then it It was just, you know, the, you needed an APL terminal. It had APL symbols printed on the, on the keys and, and could display them. But yeah, I got my, the Princeton University bookstore was an amazing place. We would go to the U store. We called it all the time for, for various things. I, I was into like drafting and all kinds of,
我玩的东西，你是不是就像，听起来你就像是偷偷溜进去然后自学，你有 APL 手册之类的吗？或者你当时是怎么，因为这不是一件简单的事情，哦，我已经看透了这个统一码（Unicode）符号的含义，现在我知道它是什么意思了，哦，老兄，这是在统一码出现之前，是的，那时没有统一码，它只是，你知道的，你需要一个 APL 终端。它的键上印有 APL 符号，并且可以显示它们。但是，是的，我得到了，普林斯顿大学书店是一个神奇的地方。我们总是去 U-Store 买各种东西。我喜欢制图和各种各样的东西，
all kinds of stuff I could, I could get exposed to there and they had the APL manual there. So that's how I got it. That is amazing. And is that the last time that you programmed an APL? Have you ever used APL more recently? I have not. I remember, you know, maybe two of the symbols, maybe, and what they did, but I remember the principle. I mean, there is this, if I remember right, this is where I learned about lazy evaluation. I think APL does a whole bunch of matrix stuff lazily, so you don't end up spending a lot of cycles on elements you're not going to actually observe yeah it's uh this this further adds to my confusion on how at some point people haven't taken apl and just made a gpu version i guess technically there's been a little bit of research by an individual by named aaron shu's made a GPU APL compiler, but like, I haven't
我能在那里接触到各种各样的东西，他们有 APL 手册。这就是我得到它的方式。这太神奇了。那是你最后一次用 APL 编程吗？你最近还用过 APL 吗？没有。我记得，你知道，大概两个符号，也许，以及它们是做什么的，但我记得原理。我的意思是，如果有我没记错的话，这就是我了解延迟求值的地方。我认为 APL 以延迟的方式做了大量矩阵的事情，所以你最终不会在那些你实际上不会观察到的元素上花费大量周期。是的，这，这进一步增加了我的困惑，为什么在某些时候人们没有把 APL 拿来直接做一个 GPU 版本，我想技术上有一个叫阿伦·舒（Aaron Shu）的人做过一点研究，他制作了一个 GPU APL 编译器，但是，我没有
actually heard that APL was used for graphic stuff. Like it makes complete sense. Cause yeah, of all the matrix operations and whatnot, but it seems like the, the stepping stone into GPU land, but I, I guess by the time GPU showed up in the whatever nineties that APL had already started its decline. So maybe, maybe that has something to do with it. Yeah. You know, I think the very thing that, that attracted me so much is also part of the reason that people aren't pursuing it. It's the stuff that's probably of lasting value in APL are the semantic bits and the syntax is, you impossible to remember and and can be hard to read and you know so that's why i don't remember it anymore right but but yeah the the semantics
实际上听说 APL 被用于图形处理。这完全讲得通。因为，是的，所有的矩阵运算等等，但这似乎是进入 GPU 领域的踏步机，但是，我想当 GPU 在九十年代左右出现时，APL 已经开始衰落了。所以也许，也许这与此有关。是的。你知道，我认为正是那个非常吸引我的东西，也是人们没有继续追求它的部分原因。APL 中可能具有持久价值的东西是语义部分，而语法是不可能记住的，而且可能很难阅读，你知道的，所以这就是为什么我不记得它的原因了，对吧，但是，是的，语义
of the operations were pretty interesting you could encode all of those in something that was easier for people you know lay people to read and and that might be an interesting system right yeah all right so where did you you went you were caught connor's only slightly distraught because connor thinks apl is the most beautiful thing in the world well no so well i it's gorgeous i i want to uh i continue on the on the journey of of dave's history but in the back of my head there's a whole other conversation of you know it's like it's hard to read you know, and this, this topic has come up in multiple different, you know, podcasts, conversations, slash whatever, just chatting on zoom is, you know, readability,
这些操作非常有趣，你可以将所有这些编码成对人们来说更容易理解的东西，你知道，外行也能读懂，那可能是一个有趣的系统，对吧，好的，那么你去哪里了，你被抓住了，康纳只是有点心烦意乱，因为康纳认为 APL 是世界上最美丽的东西，不，所以，嗯，它太华丽了，我想要，嗯，继续戴夫的历史之旅，但在我的脑海深处，还有另一场关于它的对话，你知道，就像，它很难读，你知道，而且，这个话题已经在多个不同的，你知道的，播客、对话或其它什么中出现过了，只是在 Zoom 上聊天，你知道，可读性，
like what is really readability, like readability is informed by one's experience, someone who speaks Chinese and has read Chinese growing up, like Chinese is readable to them, because that's what they learned. But to a Westerner that does not speak or read Chinese, it seems overwhelming. You have to memorize 4,000 logograms and it's not combining just a set of, you know, alphanumeric or I shouldn't say alphanumeric, just alphabetical characters. And so you have to find a way to like objectively remove experience. And then how do you answer the question of what truly is more expressive or more readable than, than one thing, just because 99% of all programming languages, you sort of use English or, you know, keywords and whatnot. Does that truly make APL less readable or is it just more unfamiliar than everything that people
比如什么是真正的可读性，可读性是由一个人的经验决定的，一个说中文并在成长过程中读中文的人，比如中文对他们来说是可读的，因为那是他们学到的。但对于不会说或读中文的西方人来说，这似乎势不可挡。你必须背诵 4000 个语标，而且它不只是结合了一组，你知道的，字母数字或者我不应该说是字母数字，只是字母字符。所以你必须找到一种方法，客观地消除经验。然后你如何回答什么是真正比其他东西更有表现力或可读性的问题，仅仅因为 99% 的编程语言，你都在某种程度上使用英语或者，你知道的，关键字等等。这真的让 APL 的可读性变差了，还是它只是比人们
are used to? And I don't even have the answer to that question. I just think it's a very interesting question. Yeah. I'm not saying that I'm not even sure that I said it's not readable. I don't think it's, I don't think it makes a great communication medium for a large audience because it is a challenge to learn and not many people have learned it, but you know, you also, when the imperatives get strong enough, people will learn all kinds of things. Right. Right.
习惯的一切更加陌生？我甚至没有这个问题的答案。我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的问题。是的。我不是说我甚至不确定我说过它不可读。我不认为它，我不认为它为广大受众提供了一个很好的沟通媒介，因为它学习起来是一个挑战，没有多少人学过它，但是，你知道，你也会发现，当必要性变得足够强大时，人们会学习各种各样的东西。对。对。
And, you know, for example, Chinese, you know, very objectively computationally difficult. But if it's what, you know, you're brought up in and what you need to survive, then of course you will learn it right and i think one of the the main roles of of programming in the modern age is as it's about
而且，你知道，例如中文，你知道，非常客观地从计算上讲很困难。但如果它是，你知道的，你成长所处的环境，以及你生存所需要的，那么你当然会学会它，对吧，而且我认为现代编程中编程的主要角色之一是，
communicating to people and you know i think communicating stuff to the to the computer is is fine but syntactic sugar sugar actually counts. Right. No, no. Well, there's a whole, there's a whole, I went on CPP chat one time and the title of the episode was, I really like sugar because at some point, you know, I'd heard, oh, lambdas are just sugar, you know, structure bindings are just sugar, but I never really understood that because it's sort of like saying like that, that's a bad thing, but like one, most people really enjoy sugar. And two, I think it's, it's sort of, it misses the point, like something that is more expressive or easier to digest. Like lambdas have completely changed the way that people can understand and read generic algorithms because you don't have to, Oh, there's
它是关于与人交流的，你知道，我认为与计算机交流东西是好的，但语法糖实际上很重要。对。不，不。好吧，有一次，有一次我上了 CPP Chat，那集节目的标题是，我真的很喜欢 sugar，因为在某个时候，你知道，我听说过，哦，lambda 只是 sugar，你知道，结构化绑定只是 sugar，但我从来没有真正理解这一点，因为这有点像是说，那是件坏事，但像第一，大多数人都真的很喜欢 sugar。第二，我认为这，这有点抓不住重点，就像更有表现力或更容易消化的东西。就像 lambda 完全改变了人们理解和阅读通用算法的方式，因为你不必，哦，有一个
a function object that's been defined somewhere else. Like you can just, it's, it's there, you see the customization and it is then more readable. It's it's yes, sure. It is just sugar for a function object, but yeah, I completely agree that something that is syntactically more expressible than an equivalent thing that sure. It's just sugar. It, it changes the program, not semantically, but definitely from a readability perspective. Yeah, sure. I mean, or, you know, if you, all you care about is is the semantics we could all program in assembly language and be just as happy right but we don't so that official statement from dave abrams we should have this uh program in assembly if we only care about semantics
在其他地方定义的函数对象。就像你可以直接，它就在那里，你看到定制，然后它就更可读了。它是，是的，当然，它只是函数对象的 sugar，但我完全同意，在语法上比等效东西更有表现力的东西，当然。它只是 sugar。它改变了程序，不是在语义上，而是绝对从可读性的角度。是的，当然，或者，你知道，如果你，你关心的只是语义，我们都可以用汇编语言编程，也会同样高兴，对吧，但我们没有，所以这是戴夫·艾布拉姆斯的官方声明，如果我们只关心语义，我们就应该用汇编语言编程
yeah if we don't care about syntax sugar i mean that's like all programming languages are syntax sugar, right? And at some level. And if there was a huge community of people that already understood how to read APL, I think the imperatives would be very different and maybe more research into using APL on things would happen. And some people argue, sometimes it's me, that there is like an order, two orders of magnitude in your ability to think and solve problems due to having like what, you know, Iverson originally wasn't called APL. It was called Iverson notation. And his Turing Award paper, which listeners of this, the listener of this podcast is a notation as a tool of thought. He never really wanted it to be a programming language.
是的，如果我们不在乎语法糖，我的意思是，那就像所有的编程语言都是语法糖，对吧？在某种程度上。如果有一个庞大的社群已经知道如何阅读 APL，我认为必要性会非常不同，也许会有更多关于在事情上使用 APL 的研究。有些人认为，有时是我，由于拥有，你知道的，艾弗森（Iverson）最初不叫 APL。它被称为艾弗森符号。他的图灵奖论文，这个播客的听众，这个播客的听众是一个作为思考工具的符号。他从来没想过它成为一门编程语言。
It was a language, a notation for expressing algorithms. And at some point someone realized they were just like, we could probably implement the IBM 360 in this. And they were like, oh, okay, let's give it a spin. And yeah, I think it's worth learning just for the ability to be able to solve a problem differently. But yeah, we'll put a pin in this because we need, or sorry, go ahead.
它是一门语言，一种表达算法的符号。在某个时候，有人意识到他们只是觉得，我们或许可以用这个实现 IBM 360。然后他们就像，哦，好吧，让我们试一试。是的，我认为仅凭能够以不同方式解决问题的能力，它就值得学习。但是，是的，我们会把这个搁置一下，因为我们需要，或者抱歉，请继续。
And then we'll get back to what happened after APL. Was it small talk was the next chapter, but sorry. Yeah, go ahead. Yeah. Well, okay. I want to endorse your position. I mean, I, I think APL is totally worth learning. It's, it's great to have, uh, you know, new perspectives on programming. I think the operator composition that they do in APL is really, really interesting and, and expressive. And, and I also want to say I was, I was in C++ deeply for such a long time and, and the just doing Swift changed my perspective on programming language design and the trade-offs and everything so much that, uh, that I, I think it's, it's really super valuable to immerse yourself in, in something truly different than what you're used to. So if you haven't tried APL, it's worth a shot.
然后我们会回到 APL 之后发生了什么。是 Smalltalk 作为下一章吗？但抱歉。是的，请继续。好吧，好吧。我想赞同你的立场。我的意思是，我认为 APL 完全值得学习。拥有一门，你知道的，关于编程的新视角真是太棒了。我认为他们在 APL 中做的操作符组合真的非常非常有趣且富有表现力。而且，我也想说，我，我长期深入使用 C++，并且，仅仅使用 Swift 就极大地改变了我对编程语言设计、权衡和一切的看法，以至于，我认为，将自己沉浸在真正不同于你习惯的东西中，真的是超级有价值的。所以如果你还没尝试过 APL，值得一试。
Yeah. There's a, I'm not even sure the quote pertains to programming languages, but I saw a quote once that was, you don't really understand fully a language until and you know, C plus plus, like don't go learn Java, like go learn prologue or APL or Lisp or something that's in a completely different paradigm. Cause Java, you'll learn a couple of things, but for the most part, it's, it's got a lot of the core that's the same, but if you go learn, you know, prologue or small talk or something, it's going to bend the way that you think about the programming world. Yep. Okay. Yeah. So let's APL chapter APL chapter has ended at Princeton. Uh, and then, and then, and then what happened next? Yeah. So, uh, so I went off to college and college. Well, I, I was, I was interested in a lot of different things and, and, uh, I remember, I remember asking, uh, all of the, all of the people that came around to hype their schools, whether that kind of studying lots of different areas was going to be supported. And I remember when I asked the Carnegie Mellon person
是的。有一个，我甚至不确定这句话是否适用于编程语言，但我曾经看到过一句话是，你直到，你知道的，C++，不要去学 Java，去学 Prolog 或 APL 或 Lisp 或其他完全不同范式的东西，因为 Java，你会学到一两样东西，但大多数情况下，它的核心很多都是一样的，但是如果你去学，你知道的，Prolog 或 Smalltalk 或类似的东西，它会扭曲你对编程世界的思考方式。没错。好的。是的。所以让我们把 APL 的篇章在普林斯顿结束。然后，然后，然后接下来发生了什么？是的，所以，嗯，我上了大学，大学。好吧，我，我，我对很多不同的事情感兴趣，并且，嗯，我记得，我记得问过，嗯，所有那些来宣传他们的学校的人，这种学习很多不同领域是否会得到支持。我还记得当我问卡耐基梅隆大学的人
about this, they said, well, we don't encourage dilettantism. And so that school was crossed off my list but the but the the woman who came to talk about pen was really excited when i asked this and and so you know and when i got in and visited the campus it just felt it felt like home so so that's where i ended up going. And I wasn't really sure what I wanted to focus on, but I enrolled in computer science to was using. So another big mainframe with lots of terminals and yeah, let's see other programming languages during that time, I guess I was exposed to Lisp. There was actually a Lisp machine there, which was a pretty interesting thing. And I think this is probably also around the time when I picked up Emacs, which has a whole backend in Lisp and has stuck with my muscle memory ever since. So that's still how I, how I do a lot of things on a computer. Emacs. All right. So we don't need to ask that question or start any. Yeah. Emacs
关于这个时，他们说，嗯，我们不鼓励泛泛而学。所以那所学校被从我的名单上划掉了，但是，但是那个来谈论宾夕法尼亚大学的女士当我问这个时真的很兴奋，所以，你知道，当我被录取并参观校园时，它只是感觉，感觉就像家一样，所以，这就是我最终去的地方。我不太确定我想专注于什么，但我注册了计算机科学，使用的是。所以另一个有很多终端的大型机，是的，让我们看看那段时间的其他编程语言，我想我接触到了 Lisp。那里实际上有一台 Lisp 机器，这是一件非常有趣的事情。我想这可能也是我开始接触 Emacs 的时候，它有一个完整的 Lisp 后端，并且从那以后一直留在我的肌肉记忆中。所以这仍然是我，我如何在电脑上做很多事情的方式。Emacs。好的。所以我们不需要问那个问题或开始任何。是的。Emacs
are good. Yeah. Yeah. That's just, uh, you know, what already works for me. So that's what I do. After, after college, I wasn't really sure what I wanted to do, but got a, got accepted to Carnegie Mellon graduate program in computer science, spent a year there where I found myself spending at least as much time working on music and, and playing music as I did on computer science, decided I wanted to go to Berkeley College of Music, which is Berkeley with the two E's in Boston, went to Boston, spent a semester at Berkeley, realized I was really done with school. And at that point I needed to get a job. And so I got my first real professional job, which was doing computer music software for a company called Mark of the Unicorn, which they had a program called Composer and they wanted to, they wanted to improve it. I guess the person that had been working on it had
很好。是的。是的，这只是，你知道的，什么对我管用，所以我就做什么。大学毕业后，我不确定自己想做什么，但被卡耐基梅隆大学计算机科学研究生项目录取了，在那里呆了一年，发现自己花在音乐和演奏音乐上的时间至少和花在计算机科学上的一样多，决定去伯克利音乐学院，也就是波士顿那个有两个 e 的伯克利，去了波士顿，在伯克利呆了一个学期，意识到我对学校真的很厌倦了。当时我需要找份工作。所以找到了我的第一份真正的专业工作，是在一家名为 Mark of the Unicorn 的公司做计算机音乐软件，他们有一个名为 Composer 的程序，他们想，他们想改进它。我猜那个一直在开发它的人已经
left. Maybe, maybe that was Robin. She had the, I think she left to go to Adobe strangely enough. And, you know, I, I was, I looked at it and I thought, you know, this seems a little bit clunky. Maybe I can do better. They, they had a mentor for me there who had built a really successful product. And so they said, okay, go and do that with this guy because I had never done any real professional programming before. And of course, this guy quit once he met me. Now he quit shortly thereafter. So I was basically, I was basically, you know, on my own learning how to, to write software, learning how to write a Mac application, um, with the responsibility of writing this entire application, uh, on my shoulders. What language is this in at the time?
离开了。也许，也许那是罗宾（Robin）。她有，我想她奇怪地离开去 Adobe 了。而且，你知道，我，我看了看它，心想，你知道，这看起来有点笨拙。也许我可以做得更好。他们在那里为我安排了一位导师，他开发过一个非常成功的产品。所以他们说，好吧，去跟这个人一起做吧，因为我以前从未做过任何真正的专业编程。当然，这个人一见到我就辞职了。现在他没多久就辞职了。所以我基本上，我基本上，你知道的，靠自己学习如何编写软件，学习如何编写 Mac 应用程序，肩负着编写整个应用程序的责任，
What language was I, I think to start with, I only had C yeah, I only had C and at some point in my first year, I discovered I was reading bite magazine and there was this, this thing you could download that was essentially a little small talk. And so small talk does come into the picture. Yeah, I guess so. It wasn't actually Smalltalk. It was a tiny object-oriented language. You know, basically dynamic dispatch, you know, was the key thing.
当时这是什么语言？我用的是什么语言，我想一开始，我只有 C，是的，在我第一年的某个时候，我发现我正在读 Byte 杂志，有一个，你可以下载的东西，本质上是一个小型的 Smalltalk。所以 Smalltalk 确实进入了画面。是的，我想是的。它实际上不是 Smalltalk。它是一个微型的面向对象语言。你知道的，基本上动态分派，你知道的，是关键所在。
So you had methods and you had dynamic dispatch. And something clicked with me where I thought, oh, this is how user interfaces should be built. And so I built an object-oriented programming system on top of C using horrible macros and conventions and whatnot. And so that was the back end was the backend of my product, which was eventually called Composer's Mosaic. So that was that job. I went on from that to do all kinds of other interesting things in computer music in that job and spent 11 years there, which I have to say, I've said this before. It was a hugely, it was a huge growth experience for me to spend that much time with my own code and having to, having to live with my own mistakes because you really learn what is going to work in the things I noticed, especially once, you know, the internet started to heat up and everything was a lot of people were taking jobs and working there for a year
所以你有方法，也有动态分派。有些东西触动了我，我想，哦，这就是用户界面应该构建的方式。所以我使用可怕的宏和约定等等，在 C 之上构建了一个面向对象编程系统。所以那是后端，是我的产品的后端，该产品最终被称为 Composer's Mosaic。所以那就是那份工作。在那份工作中，我继续做各种其他有趣的计算机音乐事情，并在那里呆了 11 年，我必须说，我以前说过。对我来说，花这么多时间在自己的代码上，不得不，不得不与自己的错误共存，是一次巨大的成长经历，因为你真正了解了什么会在这些事情中起作用，我注意到，特别是一旦，你知道的，互联网开始升温，每个人都在找工作并在那里工作一年
and handing their coat off to somebody else and, and leaving. And I, I thought those people are missing out. Is there, well, advice or like, what is the, what are some of the key things that you took away that you think people are missing out from not spending that amount of time? Uh, or that is only sort of lessons you can learn, or maybe they're not things that you can be captured in a podcast bite and it's stuff you have to actually just experience. Uh, well, you know, I think, I think a lot of it could have been, I, a lot of pain I could have not gone through if I'd had somebody to mentor me at that time who knew more of these things. behavior of things, right? Getting it right is about that. And, you know, just how much to not let yourself get away with in terms of, you know, oh, it seems to work and, you know, what kinds of reinforcements to build in.
然后把外套交给别人就离开了。而且，我，我心想这些人错过了。有没有，嗯，建议或者，有哪些你带走的，你认为人们因为没有花那么多时间而错过的事情的关键点？或者这只是你只能学到的教训，或者也许它们不是可以用播客片段捕捉的东西，而是你必须亲自去体验的东西？嗯，你知道，我，我认为，很多事情都可以，如果当时有人指导我了解更多这些事情，我可以避免经历很多痛苦。事情的行为，对吧？把事情做好就是关于这一点。而且，你知道，在，你知道的，哦，似乎可行，以及，你知道的，建立什么样的强化机制方面，不要让自己放纵多少。
I went through a long phase around this time when I would explicitly write out asserts and about all my preconditions and insert invariants all over the place, like I was implementing contract programming in my software. And I learned a lot from that. It got to the point, you know, eventually, if you do that enough, you get to the point where you, you can see logically that your software is correct and you don't need these kinds of reinforcements. But, but that was a, that was a huge learning experience for me. Another interesting thing was just about some of the trade-offs that I made in my initial designs. My initial design for this notation software was designed around conserving every byte because memory was really constrained at that time. You know, you get a 128K Mac on your desktop.
在这个时期，我经历了一个漫长的阶段，我会明确写出断言，关于我所有的前置条件，并在各处插入不变式，就像我在软件中实现契约式编程一样。我从中学到了很多。到了那种程度，你知道的，最终，如果你做得够多，你就会达到那种程度，你可以从逻辑上看出你的软件是正确的，你不需要这些类型的强化机制。但是，但是对我来说，这是一次巨大的学习经历。另一个有趣的事情是关于我在初始设计中所做的一些权衡。我最初为这个记谱软件做的设计是围绕节省每一个字节展开的，因为当时内存非常受限。你知道，桌面上只有 128K 的 Mac。
This is what people were doing this work with. And so I developed this really compact encoding for the notation. But then what I discovered in the long run was actually to be able to manipulate this notation stuff, I needed to build a much more expensive dynamic data structure on top of it with just essentially a decompressed version of it. But it was very hard ever to get rid of this underlying encoding that I had. So just being able to think about,
人们就是用这个来做这项工作的。所以我为这个记谱法开发了一种非常紧凑的编码。但后来我从长远来看发现，为了能够操作这些记谱法的东西，我需要在它之上构建一个成本高得多的动态数据结构，本质上是它的解压版本。但要摆脱我拥有的底层编码非常困难。所以能够思考，
think about, you know, what it's going to cost you to optimize over here. That was one of the, one of the big lessons. So you, you spend 11 years, you said, uh, working on that. And then what caught, what caught, what, or slash, what's the kind of time period and what caused you to, to, you were looking for your next challenge or. Yeah. Well, so it was toward the end of my my stay there that well this is like c++ is sort of starting to come into its own so the the
思考，你知道的，在这里进行优化会让你付出什么代价。那是其中一个，一个巨大的教训。所以你，你花了 11 年，你说了，嗯，在上面工作。然后是什么引起了，什么引起了，或者换句话说，是什么时间段以及是什么促使你，你在寻找下一个挑战还是。是的。好吧，所以那是接近我在那里逗留的尾声，嗯，这就像 C++ 开始崭露头角，所以
language we're using next after c at mark of the unicorn was something called think c which which was essentially c with with a kind of dynamic dispatch object system on top of it kind of objective c like and uh and then c++ comes along and during this time so i i my friend next door mark waxler, showed me the interview with Alex Stepanov and Dr. Dobbs. And I was like, oh, this STL thing, I've got to get this. Because I don't think people understand, but at that time, there were no libraries. There were really no libraries. Like if you wanted to do anything, you had to write it yourself. Okay. There was Q sort, right? There was C's Q sort. There were no, there were no frameworks for, for user interfaces. There were, there were basically, so there was nothing. So, so we were
我们在 Mark of the Unicorn 使用 C 之后的下一个语言被称为 Think C，它基本上是 C，上面有一种带有动态分派对象系统的东西，有点像 Objective-C，然后 C++ 出现了，在这期间，所以我的隔壁朋友马克·瓦克斯勒（Mark Waxler）给我看了亚历克斯·斯捷帕诺夫（Alex Stepanov）在 Dr. Dobbs 上的采访。我说，哦，这个 STL 东西，我必须得到这个。因为我不认为人们理解，但在那个时候，没有库。真的没有库。就像如果你想做任何事，你都得自己写。好吧，有 Q sort，对吧？有 C 的 Q sort。没有任何用于用户界面的框架，基本上，所以什么都没有。所以，我们在
developing everything from scratch and and you know i wrote binary search wrong about 50 times okay uh did uh to skip ahead did sean give you that question upon hiring you at adobe uh to write a binary search yeah that's the one that they asked a modified binary search or did you said he was going to exempt me from it oh okay so could have been a different outcome if he had asked you to write it yeah that's true that's true you think you would have gotten it right uh that time uh probably at this point uh i i yeah i think i think if i didn't rush through it i think i wouldn't have rushed through it actually because because i still remember getting it wrong so many times yeah right um but yeah now now I believe I know how to think about
从头开始开发一切，你知道的，我把二分查找写错了大约 50 次，好吧，嗯，为了跳过，肖恩在 Adobe 雇佣你时有没有问你那个问题，让你写一个二分查找，是的，那是他们问的，一个修改过的二分查找，或者你说他要豁免我？哦，好吧，如果他让你写，结果可能会不同，是的，那是真的，那是真的，你觉得你那次能写对吗，可能在这一点上，我，是的，我想，如果我没有匆忙完成它，我想我其实不会匆忙完成它，因为因为我还记得把它写错了很多次，对，嗯，但是，是的，现在我相信我知道如何思考
binary search. So when I saw this article on the STL, and then I discovered that the thing actually had documented requirements and guarantees, unlike any of the code that I had written, because I'm writing music software. It's't, I'm, it's not my, it's not what I'm not being paid to, to write a binary search. I'm not being paid to be good at, at sort. I'm being paid to be good, to be a, actually, you know, it's a tiny niche, but I was a world-class expert in music software. Okay. And I think this is, I think this is, is typical and, and correct that, you know, people get paid to become domain experts and, and do something they're really good at and apply that expertise. And you can't be an expert in everything. And so this is one
二分查找。所以当我看到这篇关于 STL 的文章时，然后我发现这个东西实际上有文档化的需求和保证，不像我写过的任何代码，因为我在写音乐软件。它不是，我不是，我写二分查找不是为了拿薪水。我擅长排序不是为了拿薪水。我拿薪水是因为我擅长，实际上，你知道的，这是一个微小的利基市场，但我是音乐软件领域的世界级专家。好的。而且我认为这，我认为这，是典型且正确的，你知道的，人们拿薪水是为了成为领域专家，并做他们真的很擅长的事情并应用这种专业知识。你不可能成为所有事情的专家。所以这也是原因之一，
of the reasons, you know, I think I was so enamored when Boost came along that libraries are so important. In any case, I find this STL and it's got documented requirements and guarantees and complexity. And I'm like, what? I can actually think about when I put these two pieces together, what the overall cost is going to be. Is it going to be efficient? You know, this was amazing. This is not what anybody did. And sadly, I would say it's still not what anybody does.
你知道，我想当我加入 Boost 时我是多么着迷，库是如此重要。无论如何，我发现了这个 STL，它有文档化的需求、保证和复杂度。我说，什么？当我把这两部分放在一起时，我实际上可以考虑总成本会是多少。它会高效吗？你知道的，这太神奇了。这不是任何人做的事。可悲的是，我想说这依然不是任何人做的事。
Pretty much. Well, you know, maybe I think it got into the C++ culture a bit. So that's good. But I think if you look in industry, I think in general, people are not careful about documenting requirements, guarantees, and especially complexity. But this made a huge difference for me. But I looked at this and we were still working on systems without virtual memory. And so running out of memory was a real thing. And what was C++'s answer to running out of memory? It was to throw an exception. And at the time when I got the STL, the language that came with it said, the documentation said, if an exception is thrown inside of any of this, if you throw an exception while sorting, whatever, all bets are off,
差不多。好吧，你知道，也许我认为它稍微进入了 C++ 文化。所以那很好。但我认为如果你看行业，我认为总的来说，人们并不关心记录需求、保证，尤其是复杂度。但这对我产生了巨大的影响。但我看了这个，我们还在没有虚拟内存的系统上工作。所以内存耗尽是一件真实的事情。C++ 对内存耗尽的回答是什么？是抛出异常。在我拿到 STL 的时候，随之而来的语言说，文档说，如果这里面的任何地方抛出了异常，如果你在排序时抛出异常，无论什么，所有的赌注都取消了，
your program is going to crash. Maybe if you're lucky, right? If you're unlucky, it launches the missiles. So being in this environment where we had to deal with out of memory, I already had some idea of how to handle errors. And I looked at this and I thought, well, this is just not that hard. Just do what I always do for handling errors. Well, it turned out to be a more sophisticated thing than that, but it was basically, I thought we could solve this problem. So I actually wrote a message to Alex, found Alex's address and, and said, you know, I'm thinking I could fix this problem. And, and he said, he wrote back and said, I, I think that's great. But you should be aware that they're like already two years behind in finalizing the
你的程序就要崩溃了。也许如果你运气好的话，对吧？如果你运气不好，它就会发射导弹。所以在这个必须处理内存不足的环境中，我已经对如何处理错误有了一些概念。我看了看这个，心想，嗯，这其实没那么难。就做我平时处理错误时做的事就好了。嗯，结果这比我想象的要复杂一些，但基本上，我觉得我们可以解决这个问题。所以我真的给亚历克斯写了一条消息，找到了亚历克斯的地址，并且说，你知道的，我在想我可以修复这个问题。然后他说，他回信说，我，我觉得这很好。但你应该意识到，他们已经落后标准最终确定进度大概两年了。
standard. It was supposed to be done in 96 or 95 or something like that. And, and, you know, you're going to have a hard sell to make any changes at this point. And, but, but he said, here, let me put you in touch with, I think it was Greg Colvin that he put me in touch with, possibly. He either put me in touch with him or Andy Koenig. And at some point I got onto what they called the reflectors. Is the committee still using reflectors? We still call them that. And it's probably still hosted in the same place.
这个标准本应在96年或95年左右完成，诸如此类。而且，你知道的，要在目前这个时候做出任何改动，你将会面临一场艰难的推销。但是，但是他说，来，我把你引见给——我想是格雷格·科尔文（Greg Colvin），他把我引见给了格雷格，也有可能是安迪·科尼格（Andy Koenig）。在某个时候，我进入了他们所说的反射器（reflectors）。委员会现在还在使用反射器吗？我们仍然这样叫它们。而且它可能仍然托管在同一个地方。
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Mailman? Yep. All right. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Mailman. Yep. All right. Cool. So I got on the reflectors and started talking about this on the library working group. And one of the things, so I definitely heard from a lot of people, we don't have time to deal with this. We're already behind. I also heard this is well known to be an impossible problem to solve. I'm paraphrasing.
对。好吧。对。邮件列表（Mailman）？是的。好的。对。好吧。对。邮件列表。是的。好的。太棒了。所以我加入了反射器，并在库工作组上开始讨论这件事。其中一件事，所以我确实听到很多人说，我们没有时间处理这个。我们已经落后了。我还听说，众所周知，这是一个无法解决的 impossible 问题。我是在意译。
I don't know whether they actually said impossible, but it was, there was a common wisdom that exception safety was not something that we could handle. And a lot of it came from this article, the way people read this article by Tom Cargill, which was a classic at that point about why especially generics and exception safety was a difficult problem. And while Cargill didn't say it was impossible to solve, he pointed out a lot of problems. And a lot of people read this to be a demonstration that it just wasn't tractable. So actually getting exception safety into the standard is how I developed my appreciation for the consensus process, I think, in large part. At some point, so I made my arguments on the reflector. At some point, Andy Koenig said, well, that's all very well and good, but you're not going to get anything accomplished unless you
我不知道他们是否真的说过不可能，但当时有一种共识，即异常安全性不是我们能够处理的事情。其中很大一部分来自于这篇文章，人们阅读汤姆·卡吉尔（Tom Cargill）这篇文章的方式，这在当时是一篇经典文章，关于为什么特别是泛型和异常安全性是一个难题。虽然卡吉尔并没有说它是无法解决的，但他指出了很多问题。很多人认为这篇文章证明了这个问题根本无法处理。所以，实际上将异常安全性引入标准的过程，我认为在很大程度上是我对共识过程产生赞赏的开始。在某个时候，我在反射器上表达了我的观点。在某个时候，安迪·科尼格说，嗯，这都很好，但除非你...
show up at a meeting. I was like, wow. Well, fortunately the next meeting was, I was in Massachusetts. It was just in New Hampshire and I got the time off work to go there. And that was, that was a really amazing experience. And, you know, I don't know that the culture has really, the stories I've heard have not been good recently about the culture and committee meetings. But at that time, one of the things I was most impressed with was how a group of such smart people with such divergent viewpoints could treat each other with such respect. And especially that I got a lot of respect, even for the things I had argued. And I tried to, you know, I realized this was not my domain. So I was not trying to like tread in heavy, but it was a really different feeling than my professional experience. I felt hugely
出现在会议上，否则你什么也做不成。我当时想，哇。幸运的是，下一次会议就在，我在马萨诸塞州。它就在新罕布什尔州，我请到了假去那里。那是一次非常了不起的经历。而且，你知道的，我不知道文化是否真的——我最近听到的关于文化和委员会会议的故事并不好。但在那个时候，给我印象最深的事情之一是，这样一群如此聪明、观点如此截然不同的人，竟然能以如此大的尊重对待彼此。尤其是，我得到了很大的尊重，甚至对于我所争论的事情也是如此。我试图，你知道的，我意识到这不是我的领域。所以我并不想深入涉足，但这与我的职业经历有着真正不同的感觉。我感到极大地...
validated by this. And so that contrast was the beginning of the end of my work at Mark of the Unicorn because I really saw that I wanted more of what we were doing in the committee. At this point, we had to stop recording due to time constraints, but we will definitely have Dave Abrahams back on to tell the rest of his story. Until then, enjoy this three minutes of bonus content from behind the scenes. Well, I'm happy to come back. I hope it was all actually interesting and I wasn't just droning on taking up time. me are you kidding me holy smokes the internet i'm just i'm gonna be putting together a team of like people that you know we're putting a team together and the person's gonna say no i'm not interested in joining but they're still gonna unofficially be on that team of uh people that used to do apl um and you were doing it in high school like oh man that was uh you was breaking into mainframes to do it in high school.
被这群人认可了。所以这种对比是我在独角兽之标（Mark of the Unicorn）工作结束的开始，因为我真的发现我想要更多我们在委员会里所做的那种事情。在这一点上，由于时间限制，我们不得不停止录制，但我们一定会请戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）回来讲完剩下的故事。在那之前，请欣赏这三分钟的幕后花絮内容。嗯，我很乐意回来。我希望这一切实际上都很有趣，而不仅仅是我在唠叨浪费时间。天哪，你在开玩笑吗，太疯狂了，互联网，我，我只是要组建一个团队，就像你知道的那样的人，我们要组建一个团队，然后这个人会说，不，我对加入不感兴趣，但他们仍然会非官方地成为那个由曾经做过APL的人组成的团队的一员，而且你是在高中时就开始做了，天哪，那是，你在高中时是靠闯入大型机来做这件事的。
That is such a, you, yeah, you were, you were sneaking around Princeton. Um, and, uh, Mark is not sneaking around to sneaking into and, and also, yeah, breaking, uh, breaking into that's, oh man, that's definitely going to be intro to whatever part one or part two of where it was just, I was so hungry for APL that I, I broke into the, that is just, oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. It wasn't, it wasn't much to break. I mean, you could see like that this was old style security, right? There's a gap between the doors and you can see the little hook. It's just like, oh, all I have to do is wiggle
这太，你，是的，你在，你在普林斯顿鬼鬼祟祟的。嗯，而且，马克可不是鬼鬼祟祟地溜进，而且，还有，是的，闯入，闯入那是，哦天哪，那绝对会成为无论哪一部分的引子，第一部分还是第二部分，我当时太渴望APL了以至于我，我闯入了，那简直是，哦天哪。哦天哪。这并没有，没费什么劲就能闯入。我的意思是，你可以看到这是一种老式的安全措施，对吧？门之间有缝隙，你可以看到那个小钩子。就像，哦，我只需要摇晃...
that thing. I consider uh cutting in uh unfortunately at this point uh dave's mic cut out but uh he had this real elaborate you know he had to at one point break the window you know this is uh his mom got in trouble from the university for all the damage property um that's where apl will take you if you're not well this this almost i almost did get i did get uh yeah at one point somebody got in trouble because because i was not not broken into the engineering building but i was using a terminal i wasn't supposed to use in fact i think i was using an account I wasn't supposed to use because some graduate student had me, he wanted to build some statistical charts. So he had me program that and he let me use this, this account that I was supposed to stop using. As a high school student, you were doing work for some of the grad students at Princeton?
我考虑过插话，不幸的是在这个时候，戴夫的麦克风断线了，但他有这个非常详细的，你知道的，他必须在某个时候打破窗户，你知道这，他的妈妈因为所有损坏的财产而惹上了大学的麻烦，这就是如果你不好好学习，APL会带你去的地方，嗯，这几乎，我差点就真的，我确实，是的，在某个时候有人惹上了麻烦，因为因为我没有闯入工程大楼，但我使用的是我不应该使用的终端，事实上，我认为我使用的是我不应该使用的账户，因为某个研究生让我，他想制作一些统计图表。所以他让我编写那个程序，并且他让我使用这个我本该停止使用的账户。作为一个高中生，你当时在为普林斯顿的一些研究生做工作？
I guess so. I mean, it was, he didn't pay me or anything. So, you know, who knows if this was even like, you know, he was legal or not to do that. I don't even know if he was supposed to do that work or whatever. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我想是的。我的意思是，他没有付给我钱什么的。所以，你知道的，谁知道这是否甚至像，你知道的，他这样做是否合法。我甚至不知道他是否应该做那项工作什么的。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。